all right so as you guys know I've spent
a lot of time on the Rubin report
talking about the current status of the
left as I've said many times I believe
the regressive left the group of people
who use illiberal tactics to silence
those defending liberal principles to be
the left's version of the Tea Party
if we don't rein them in now than the
left in America will end up as fractured
as the right evidence of the fractured
right is everywhere with basically every
mainstream conservative actively trying
to stop the party's frontrunner Donald
Trump has there ever been a time when a
front-runner on either side was so hated
by his own party's establishment not
that I know of and interestingly this
mess is actually of the GOP zone doing
they didn't see the rise of the Tea
Party until it was too late which set
the GOP establishment against their own
base ironically had the tea partiers
been willing to negotiate with anyone
perhaps the Republican Party would be in
a better state than the ideological mess
it's in right now that didn't happen
though and when you couple a fractured
right with the rise of the regressive
left who refused to talk honestly about
issues like Islamic extremism and
immigration we now have the rise of
Donald Trump before I continue let me
say a couple positive things about
Donald Trump believe it or not I
probably should have issued a trigger
warning there but get in your safe space
here we go all right he has absolutely
exposed our robotic politicians who were
bought and sold by campaign contributors
openly mocking hillary clinton for
showing up to his wedding because he
gave her a donation in many ways his
message of a broken system corrupted by
money is exactly the same thing that
Bernie Sanders is saying Trump has also
talked about America's awful trade deals
with China and Mexico and promised to
negotiate better ones and actually
there's every reason to believe that he
would be good at this
after all making deals is what he has
built his empire on people actually
attack Trump for having his Trump brand
ties made in Mexico but that actually
proves his point about our bad trade
deals he's making things to sell where
cost is cheap and profit will be maximum
as an American businessman he's doing
what's best for his biz
this by making ties in Mexico it's not
the fault of the businessman who uses
the system that's the fault of the
politicians who set up the bad deals
which enable it Trump has also brought
the issue of immigration to the front
and center of the debate he says he'll
build a wall and have Mexico pay for it
while I think that Mexico actually may
end up building the wall and paying for
it to keep Americans out if he becomes
president he makes a serious populist
point with the wall Trump always says we
either have a country or we don't a wall
in and of itself isn't racist it may not
be wise and it may not address the real
problems but when he talks in simple
language like that he scores points with
many voters having a secure border
shouldn't be a partisan issue but
because of our politically correct
climate it's become one you can be for
better border security and still not be
a bigot that shouldn't be too hard to
understand finally he has also scored
points with many people and talking
about the spread of Islamic extremism
while Trump never takes the time to make
the distinction between Islamic
extremism and the average Muslim person
he scores points by even talking about
Islamic extremism in the first place
because the left in this country refuses
to do so this failure on the left to
tackle the topic of Islamic extremism
honestly by linking doctrine with action
actually helps feed those like Trump who
come in with easy answers with no nuance
or real understanding Trump sees an
opening for an easy answer here like
banning all Muslims from entry to the
country and he runs with it turn on any
cable news channel to see the list of
bad things about Donald Trump we've
heard them all before so I'm actually
gonna take a different road here let's
talk about what the real threat of a
Donald Trump presidency is Donald Trump
is a businessman making business
decisions but he's also a reality TV
host winning the world's biggest reality
TV show over the course of his
presidential campaign Trump has made it
clear that he will say anything
literally anything just to be elected he
uses the media's need for clicks and
views to fuel his rise knowing full well
the more outlandish his statements are
and the more clownish he acts the more
free TV time he's going to get he has
master
the age-old adage any publicity is good
publicity people like Trump for his lack
of political correctness but it's not
what he says that they're responding to
it's just that he's saying nothing and
everything at the same time without
sounding like a career politician is he
really against gay marriage now even
though he used to be for it is he really
against abortion now even though he used
to be pro-choice I have no idea what's
in his heart
but I do know what's in his head he
wants to be the contestant who doesn't
get fired on the season finale many
people in this country want to feel like
America is winning again and Trump has
wisely used this notion to fuel his
campaign but the question is what does
electing Trump actually mean if he wins
does anyone think he'll actually adhere
to the Constitution will he care about
due process or respect the three
branches of government will he sue
reporters who investigate the White
House will we get into a war over a
mistake and retweet his gruff language
and loose use of facts are only the
micro problem here at the macro problem
is that nobody really knows what this
guy stands for other than winning and
that's the real risk of a trump
presidency we have no idea what the
country will look like after we elect
someone who cares more about his own
rules than the law of the land you know
he says Starbucks will put merry
Christmas back on cups when he's
president does he know that the
president doesn't get to decide what a
private company does with their products
as a businessman yeah he does know but
as a presidential candidate he doesn't
care if winning at all costs for a
temporary feel-good moment is good
enough for you then by all means you
should vote for Donald Trump but don't
be fooled you're being sold a bill of
goods by someone who only cares about
making the deal when the product sucks
don't expect to get a refund
[Music]